i
[Música]
persiguiendo grandes retos
frase que ha determinado mi vida
el canal de la mancha es sin lugar a
dudas la travesía más ruda que un
nadador de aguas abiertas pueda afrontar
consiste en nadar de inglaterra a
francia una distancia aproximada de 33
kilómetros sus fuertes corrientes
vientos y sus bajas temperaturas hace
que se vea casi imposible de realizar
han sido menos de 2000 personas en el
mundo las que lo han realizado con éxito
33 de ellos son mexicanos
muchos pensarán que para realizar una
travesía de estas es gente profesional
gente dedicada a nadar durante toda su
vida gente súper dotada o fuera de lo
normal algunos los llaman locos hoy les
puedo decir que es gente apasionada
determinada y disciplinada
cuando uno se trae una meta a un
objetivo lo primero que tiene que hacer
es creer en sí mismo en su proyecto en
su capacidad pero sobre todo en el
trabajo duro
las personas tendemos a reaccionar con
temor o incredulidad ante las grandes
ideas o hazañas pero no son las personas
inquietas y creativas las que realizan
obras monumentales grandes experimentos
escalan el monte everest o por qué no
decirlo cruzan un canal
a mis 41 años con familia tres hijos
proyectos profesionales y laborales
decidió trazar me una meta muy ambiciosa
cruzar el canal de la mancha sabiendo
todo lo que iba implicar los sacrificios
y los compromisos
la meta estaba de llegar a francia sin
parar así es
llegar a francia sin parar
tenía que reorganizar nuevamente a todos
mis tiempos cambiar hábitos rutinas
sacrificar fiestas como festivales en el
proceso rodearme de gente que cree en
los sueños que te impulse a salir
adelante
en mi vida siempre he tratado de
rodearme de gente así
gente alegre
gente apasionada gente a la cual le
aprendo
y en esta ocasión no fue la excepción
considero que la pasión la determinación
y la disciplina
son cualidades que tenemos que seguir
si queremos alcanzar un objetivo
para mí durante todo este proceso no
podía descuidar lo más importante mi
familia y mi sueño
pero a qué le llamo disciplina
levantarme todos los días a las 5 de la
mañana entrenar realizar todas mis
actividades cotidianas y realizar esas
horas de entrenamiento
entrenar 450 días consecutivos sin
descanso nadar más de 2000 kilómetros
durante toda la preparación
subir 12 kilos de peso para poder
aguantar las bajas temperaturas
o meterme una tina de agua fría a 8
grados cuando nuestra temperatura
ambiente
está a 40
a la congruencia con el sueño es lo que
yo le llamo disciplina
cuando nos trazamos la meta y el
objetivo siempre tenemos que procurar un
plan de trabajo
el metas y objetivos a corto y mediano
plazo
organizar los procesos la programación
nada se puede dejar atrás ni al azar
donde juntarte con triunfadores para
convertirte en una mejor versión de ti
mismo para mí
los objetivos se iniciaron venciendo el
miedo a nadar en aguas oscuras no
sabiendo qué animal o qué embarcación
podría pasar
la segunda meta
ya no una más era nadar en aguas oscuras
era cubrir una distancia de 35 km
esto lo realice en la costa yucateca 12
horas de nado
lo recuerdo porque tuve la oportunidad
de compartir unas brazadas con mi hija
la tercera meta
consistía en nadar en aguas frías
me fui a las costas de san francisco a
nadar a 15 grados durante 8 horas
y someterá el cuerpo a un duro castigo
tratando de aguantar los calambres
derivados por el frío y por el
agotamiento
nos preguntamos
porque hacerlo
mi primera motivación fue darle un
ejemplo de vida a mis hijas
de mostrarme lo personal que los límites
los tenemos en la mente pero sobre todo
dejar un legado a mi comunidad de que no
hay sueño pequeño que no hay imposibles
que todos todos somos extraordinarios y
que si tenemos una meta un objetivo
tenemos que luchar con ello hasta
alcanzarlo
les comparto este vídeo previo a mi
cruze
este vídeo es un vídeo que me envía mi
hija desde mérida al cual
me llena de emoción porque fue lo que me
dio la herramienta para poder iniciar el
senado
[Música]
j
jajaja
[Música]
después de dos años de ardua preparación
llega el día un 25 de septiembre a la
medianoche
había frío ambientes fuertes olas de
casi 2 metros pero eso sí todo el equipo
ya estaba listo para iniciar la travesía
tanto el trabajo físico como el mental
lo habíamos preparado lo único que
faltaba
era realizar el nado
estábamos en dover y nos dirigimos a la
playa de shakespeare para iniciar la
travesía fueron 10 minutos créanme los
10 minutos más largos de mi vida
recibiendo las últimas instrucciones de
mi entrenadora nora toledano respiraba
profundo
me encomendaba a dios le pedí a la
fortaleza para iniciar el nado
no lo puedo negar en ese momento la
mente me jugaba malas pasadas tenía
dudas
las emociones estaban a flor de piel
tenía miedo mucho miedo
recuerdo el vídeo familiar
y el por qué estaba allá para
demostrarle a mis hijas que con trabajo
duro y con determinación todo se puede
lograr
me quito mi reloj
que me mide las brazadas y todas las
cosas
se le entregó a mi esposa y le dijo mi
amor nos vemos en francia
fue lo que me permitió iniciar esta
cuenta regresiva
con 3
y aquí empezamos
desde el primer momento puse a prueba mi
capacidad mental sabía que físicamente
estaba preparado para hacerlo
pero imagínense la noche oscura la
inmensidad del mar el miedo me invadía
mucho miedo hoy le llamo emociones
trataba de pensar en mi técnica de nado
y no podía trataba de pensar
en mi canción favorita sin poder
lograrlo
inclusive trataba de rezar
y no lo recordaba así que hablé con dios
pero en esta ocasión le reclamaba dios
mío porque estas condiciones tan duras
en ese momento recordé la de maría
y me aferré a rezarlo una y otra y otra
vez
fortaleciendo mi fe
ese día era el día de mi cumpleaños
así que me cantaba feliz cumpleaños en
inglés y en español para olvidar la
mente
y tratar de evitar la hipotermia por el
frío
no me lo van a creer en verdad eran
muchas emociones a flor de piel así
transcurrió 60 minutos y mi primer
abastecimiento
muy buen avance toma la temperatura
empezamos mucho y las condiciones van a
cambiar
lo único que recuerdo le quedaba una y
otra vez metas cortas brazadas tras
brazada
esperando que la noche pasara y que las
condiciones calmarían
así transcurrió
todas las noches en la mañana
recibe una advertencia
y aumenta su ritmo de brazadas o te
sacamos
ya llevaba 8 horas de nado continuo
entre mí a mí nadie me saca yo continuó
nadando
y como la vida
la naturaleza y el mar no tiene palabra
las condiciones del mar se volvieron más
adversas
habían olas de casi 2 metros
pero había que afrontarlas y teníamos
que salir adelante
terminando
esta parte del nado recuerdo volver el
estómago una y otra y otra vez el estado
me ardía me sentía mal
agarra un poco de agua de mar en juego
la boca le escupo y continúa nadando en
ese preciso momento sabía que iba a
llegar a francia ya llevaba 10 horas
una dado que para entenderlo hay que
vivirlo y experimentar cada una de las
emociones
y el apoyo del equipo fue impecable me
cuidaron cada minuto cada segundo
a 6 km antes de llegar a francia
se ve la costa todo el equipo se pare en
la popa y me empieza a echar porras para
inhumar y seguir adelante
inclusive el capitán de embarco un
inglés se pone un sombrero charro y me
motiva a seguir adelante
así transcurrieron 55 mil 500 brazadas
en 59 kilómetros 15 horas
y ocho minutos
dejando atrás
las aguas a 16 grados
no ha llegado a costas francesas en este
instante
tiene que levantar las manos y salir
totalmente del mar para que le sea
válido la gran travesía del canal de la
mancha hemos terminado gracias adiós
recuerdo haber levantado los brazos en
vez de victoria en la playa de shanghai
en francia contento y orgulloso de lo
que había hecho
recuerdo las palabras de mi madre
nunca te rindas
y posteriormente
me siento en una roca
y me pongo a llorar y me pongo a llorar
como niño recordando todo el proceso que
había pasado que el trabajo duro
había concluido
me había demostrado que todo es posible
que soy el primer yucateco en haber
cruzado el canal de la mancha 31
mexicano
las palabras no me alcanzan para
expresar el orgullo que tengo de ser
mexicano de haber podido ser congruente
de haber cubierto las expectativas
de demostrarme que todo es posible que
no hay sueño pequeño
estoy convencido
que el trabajo duro tiene sus
recompensas
que el apoyo de la gente positiva marca
la diferencia que la familia es lo más
grande que puede construir un ser humano
que el trabajo físico como el mental se
puede entrenar y elevar en forma
exorbitante
pero sobre todo que la fe en ti en tu
sueño y en nuestro creador hace que se
cristalice en las metas
hoy los reconocimientos han sido muchos
ninguno esperado pero en verdad
agradecido con todos me mantengo vivo
siguiendo la fiel en la misma fórmula
creer en ti
trabajo duro
disciplina y congruencia
hacia la antártica 2021 mi nuevo reto
los invito a soñar despiertos
persiguiendo grandes retos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]